[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans dimanche
en politique en Franche-Comté un
dimanche à nouveau spécial législatif
nous allons vous proposer tout au long
de la journée pas moins de 4 débats dans
4 circonscriptions de notre région en
partenariat avec France Bleu et l'Est
Républicain des débats à commenter sur
les réseaux sociaux avec le mot dièse
d'impol FC comme dimanche en politique
Franche-Comté le programme du jour je
vous le donne tout de suite nous irons
dans la troisième et la quatrième
circonscription du Doubs des
circonscriptions qui couvrent notamment
le Pays de Montbéliard à une partie du
Haut-Doubs et puis les premières et
troisième circonscription du Jura celle
de Dole et celle de Lons-le-Saunier on
va commencer d'ailleurs avec celle de
Lons-le-Saunier le
journaliste de l'Est Républicain
Frédéric Gimenez est en coulisse il va
le nous rejoindre dans un instant à mes
côtés Véronique narbou de France Bleu
bonjour Véronique bonjour vous allez
nous présenter nos cinq invités mais
d'abord de quelles circonscription
parlons-nous vous allez la voir il
s'agit de la première du Jura celle de
Lons-le-Saunier donc elle s'étend de
Poligny à Arato et Saint-Amour le
sortant c'est Jacques Pélissard du parti
les républicains après 24 ans de mandat
il ne se représente pas au premier tour
de la présidentielle cette
circonscription avait placé Marine Le
Pen en tête quelques points devant
Emmanuel Macron Jean-Luc Mélenchon était
3e c'est d'ailleurs son deuxième
meilleur score de Franche-Comté suivent
dans l'ordre François Fillon Nicolas
Dupont-Aignan et Benoît Hamon Véronique
c'est à vous qui sont nos invités
d'abord Cyril breiro vous êtes le
candidat des républicains vous êtes
l'attaché parlementaire du député
sortant Jacques Pélissard vous avez
également deux mandats celui de conseils
municipal à Lons-le-Saunier vous êtes
aussi conseillé départemental avec nous
aujourd'hui Daniel brûlebois madame vous
êtes conseillère départementale de
Bletterans en 2012 on vous a vu
candidate au législatif sous l'étiquette
PS cette fois vous êtes investi par la
République en marche en face de vous il
y a un homme que vous connaissez bien et
pour choses il a été votre suppléant au
législatives de 2012 marque Henri
Duvernay bonjour vous êtes aujourd'hui
le candidat titulaire pas suppléante
investi par le PS avec le soutien
d'Europe Écologie Les Verts et du Parti
communiste et vous êtes aussi conseillé
municipal d'opposition annonce le
Saunier sur ce plateau avec nous bonjour
Gabriel Amar alors vous demanda
politique vous en avez eu c'était un
petit peu plus haut en France en
Île-de-France notamment en Essonne vous
vous êtes implanté il y a quelques
années dans le Jura et aussi oui je sais
et vous êtes désormais donc candidat sur
cette terre jurassienne sous l'étiquette
France insoumise enfin Gilles Moriconi
alors vous me dire vous faites un retour
en politique après une longue pause pas
loin d'un quart de siècle on va dire
vous avez été candidat conseiller
régional Front National et vous êtes
aujourd'hui candidat sous la bannière
debout la France alors je vous précise
que sont également candidats dans cette
première circonscription du Jura Gérard
d'obligean pour le Front national nous
l'avions d'ailleurs invité à participer
à ce débat il refuser Ramazan Itek Alain
Janiot Michel Lapierre Benjamin maraud
des grottes et Johan Morel je m'adresse
pour commencer à Cyril breirot alors
vous vous avez été investi par votre
partie les républicains en janvier
dernier il y a quand même un de vos
concurrents malheureux Benjamin maraude
qui a décidé de se présenter lui aussi
on l'a dit en dissident il se verrait
bien successeur de Jacques Pélissard
est-ce qu'on doit en déduire qui comprit
dans votre propre compte n'est pas un
candidat aussi évident que cela écoutez
l'évidence elle est donnée par la
logique du parti moi je suis élu des
républicains j'ai eu l'investiture
nationale par la commission nationale
d'un instituteur puis le Conseil
national 4 jours après à Paris en
janvier je suis donc le candidat
officiel et légitime des républicains et
de Lead et de l'UDI pardonnez-moi donc
candidat l'Union de la Droite et du
centre il y a effectivement un dissident
qui aujourd'hui porte une conviction
différente de la mienne une conception
aussi de la droite et du centre surtout
de la droite très différente donc je
prends acte je le déplore mais
aujourd'hui le candidat officiellement
investi qui a la légitimité du travail
parlementaire qui est l'Égypte la
légitim dieu du travail d'élus je suis
conseiller départemental aujourd'hui
c'est moi j'ai les soutiens de très
grand nombre de militants sur ma
circonscription vous parlez d'une
conception
grotte
Dick libres et indépendante d'Emmanuel
Macron quel député serait vous par
rapport au gouvernement quelle attitude
vous aurez par rapport au Google noms si
vous êtes élu aujourd'hui à deux façons
aujourd'hui devant les choses dans notre
partie politique soit on est encore dans
les vieux clivages dans le côté où on
s'oppose systématiquement à ce que le
camp d'en face propose aujourd'hui je
pense que c'est une approche pas séiste
moi demain élue député je veux je veux
être un député constructif dans le cadre
de mes valeurs de la droite et du centre
pour que notre prend soit beaucoup plus
rassemblé faut quand même rappeler que
si on rate ce quinquennat là dans cinq
ans le Front national à mon avis ira
tout droit à l'élection présidentielle
donc on a une vraie responsabilité
encore plus donc j'assume aujourd'hui le
fait d'être un député demain constructif
et ouvert qui votera des bonnes lois
comme par exemple la réforme du Code du
travail mais par contre à l'inverse si
vous voulez un exemple inverse la hausse
de la CSG ça sera non très clair très
clairement donc député d'opposition mais
au coup par coup si je veux dire je vous
rassure j'espère tout à fait dans la
majorité parlementaire moi j'y crois
aujourd'hui on a un programme d'Emmanuel
Macron aujourd'hui c'est clair internet
que notre famille politique aujourd'hui
n'est ni dans la majorité ni dans
l'opposition on verra bien ce qu'il en
sera le 18 j'espère être dans la
majorité donc si je suis dans la
majorité le programme que nous mettons
en place s'appliquera si nous sommes
dans l'opposition je serai en fonction
des lois qui me seront proposées
constructives par rapport à ce qui est
bien pour notre pays Daniel boulbois la
République en marche vous êtes vous
étiez finalement membre du pêche jusqu'à
ce qu'en marche vous attribue
l'investiture est-ce que ça veut dire
que si vous n'aviez pas eu l'investiture
vous aurez et vous auriez soutenu
Marc-Henri Duvernay le candidat du Parti
socialiste alors j'ai été investie par
Emmanuel Macron pour être la candidate
sur Loncin et j'en suis très fier et
très heureuse je j'ai adhéré au
mouvement en marche qui correspond
beaucoup plus en restant fidèle à mes
convictions qui sont des convictions
sociales démocrates progressistes que je
que j'entends conserver et je vois que
vous pouvez répondre à ma à ma question
il y a-t-il pas un peu d'opportunisme
c’est-à-dire que vous n'aviez pas
annoncé que vous seriez
candidate clairement que vous étiez en
marche et finalement vous avez attendu
l'investiture pour pour prendre vos
distances avec le Parti socialiste non
de toute manière depuis quelques temps
je suis en désaccord avec les idées du
parti socialiste jurassien tel qu'il est
devenu et je souhaitais adhérer aux
parties au mouvement en marche parce que
j'adhère totalement au programme et à la
démarche d'Emmanuel Macron qui est de
dépasser les clivages politiques de
moraliser la vie politique et qui est
aussi de et qui est aussi de développer
l'activité économique en développant en
même temps les libertés en développant
l'égalité des chances et en développant
la justice sociale je partage sur la le
fond et je partage aussi sur la forme la
moralisation de la vie politique le
renouveau alors justement le renouveau
je veux pas être des obligeant faire du
jeunisme mais pensez-vous incarner le
renouveau prenez par Macron leur nouveau
ça n'est pas avoir 30 ans ou 40 ans le
renouveau c'est un état d'esprit c'est
une ouverture c'est être capable
d'abandonner les vieilles habitudes
politiciennes c'est être capable de
changer de logiciel et moi je pense
l'avoir prouvé puisque j'ai toujours été
en capacité de travailler au delà des
étiquetages politiques avec les élus de
tout bord et j'ai montré ma capacité à
rassembler et à rassembler les
intelligences et les énergies pour
travailler autour de projets communs et
de valeur commune alors vous venez de
jeter une pierre dans le jardin de Marc
Henri Duvernay en disant vous n'étiez
pas le plus d'accord de longue date avec
ce que devient le PS jurassien marque
Henri Duvernet au-delà des désaccords
avec Daniel Brulois sur lesquels on
viendra vous vous êtes candidats on l'a
dit PS soutenu par Europe Écologie Les
Verts LPC est-ce que ça veut dire que on
a besoin de votre candidature de
rassemblement à gauche pour faire
exister au subsister cette gauche bien
malmenée lors de la présidentielle avec
Benoît Hamon on a besoin de cette gauche
pour gagner partout dans le Jura car
c'est accord départemental PS Europe
Écologie Les Verts et Parti communiste
français concernaient trois
circonscriptions du Jura il est
quasiment unique nous portons cette
responsabilité car nous siégerons dans
l'opposition pour une vraie opposition
constructive au président Emmanuel
Macron et son gouvernement de droite
contre la hausse de la CSG sur les
retraités contre la hausse de la TVA
contre la suppression également de
l'impôt de solidarité sur la fortune
nous sommes pour inverser le système à
savoir essayer essayer et combattre pour
que nos territoires ruraux à travers
leurs services publics de la poste de la
SNCF de l'hôpital puisse continuer à
vivre et on a besoin pour cela de
députés de gauche donc nous siégerons
dans une vraie opposition constructive
dans un rassemblement est-ce que nous
avons fait dans le Jura porte l'espoir
Marc-Henri Duvernet effectivement une
caractéristique caractéristique dans le
Jura c'est que vous ressusciter la
gauche plurielle PS vers
Parti communiste et ces trois parties
qui vont très mal vous ressusciter cette
gauche plurielle parce que vous êtes sur
le point de mourir alors permettez-moi
que on réussites rien du tout nous
sommes bel et bien vivants dès lors que
c'est un rassemblement d'abord de
citoyens de militants qui croient dans
un projet politique alternatif de
société pour une alternative écologique
démocratique et sociale et les premières
propositions dont j'ai fait part et nous
reparlerons aussi tout à l'heure de
notre opposition au Center Parc pour
aller vers la transition écologique pour
aller vers la Sixième République pour
faire de la politique avec nos
concitoyens nos valeurs datent n'ont pas
d'il y a une semaine qu'un jour la
gauche a une histoire séculaire nous
avons des combats menés très forts très
indépendants durant ces décennies nous
en sommes fidèles et loyaux et c'est
comme cela que notre candidature commune
dans le département du Jura s'incarne
Gabriel Amar Véronique l'a dit en
présentation alors vous avez repris de
suite vous avez une carrière d'élus une
longue carrière d'élus derrière vous
vous avez été maire président de
communauté d'agglomération conseil
régional conseil département tout ça en
Île-de-France et puis il y a quelques
années maintenant en 2014 je crois vous
êtes installé dans le Jura pourquoi ce
choix vous repartez à zéro non c'est un
choix de vie personnelle et vous me
donnez là l'occasion de rappeler que la
France insoumise est une démarche
citoyenne sans rapport avec les parties
du vieux monde politique en mal de cumul
des mandats ou de de repolinage
ripolinage à la veille d'une élection
pour se faire une virginité après avoir
pris une belle claque aux élections
présidentielles donc il se trouve que
dans cette construction citoyenne mon
expérience mon savoir-faire a fait
qu'après avoir fait ces quatre dernières
années la courte échelle aux autres on
m'a demandé de marcher devant à mon tour
et je le fais loyalement pour cette
démarche citoyenne et pourquoi le Jura
pourquoi parce que j'y habite j'habite à
Lons-le-Saunier et était élu en
Île-de-France oui mais c'est un choix de
vie familial qui me conduit et personnel
qui me conduit à vivre à Lons-le-Saunier
depuis 2013 que le Parti communiste
avec qui a soutenu comme comme vous
Jean-Luc Mélenchon à la présidentielle
soutiennent un candidat social ah bah si
le Parti communiste a voté Jean-Luc
Mélenchon vous considérez que c'est une
trahison non absolument pas le Parti
communiste avait depuis janvier 2016
prévue une démarche autonome pour
l'élection présidentielle et l'élection
législative dans leur démarche autonomie
il y avait le soutien à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon mais il y avait aussi une
démarche autonome pour les élections
législatives donc c'est sans surprise ni
pour moi ni pour les électeurs et la
France insoumise elle dans sa démarche
citoyenne avait bien annoncé qui aurait
une cohérence politique en dehors des
parties traditionnelles qui feraient
d'un tout de la présidentielle et de
l'élection législative
Gilles Moriconi vous vous êtes en l'a
dit candidat de Debout la France le
parti du souverainisme Nicolas
Dupont-Aignan on a tous en mémoire
l'alliance Front national de vous la
France pour le second tour de la
présidentielle est-ce que c'est crédit
ou même tout simplement compréhensible
aujourd'hui pour les électeurs de venir
leur dire votez pour debout la France
est une voix singulière par rapport à
celle du FN tout à fait ce qu'a fait du
Nicolas Dupont-Aignan c'est prendre une
position de second tour c'est une
position courageuse
qui a consisté à dire tout simplement
tout sauf
l'ultralibéralisme prôné par Monsieur
Macron
c'est aussi simple que cela c'est une
démarche courageuse c'est assez rare en
politique
ceci étant nous gardons notre
spécificité et si j'ai quitté en 93
c'est gentil d'avoir rappelé que c'était
un quart de siècle ou presque le Front
national c'est pour une raison très
simple c'est une machine à perdre les
élections et on le voit depuis 95 on
nous promet des victoires et ils perdent
en permanence et leur comportement ils
sont au second tour plus souvent que
debout la France quand même ça je vous
l'accorde mais ce qui compte c'est pas
d'être au second tour c'est de gagner on
les a pas encore voulu juste pour gagner
est-ce que vous n'auriez pas dû vous
entendre avec le candidat Front national
de cette circonscription mais moi-même
je ne souhaite pas qu'il y ait d'entente
il faut bien comprendre que nous sommes
différents et que le comportement du
Front national stérilise les idées qu'il
porte quand bien même les idées sont
parfois intéressantes mais du coup
encore une fois ça n'est pas très
lisible pour les électeurs que de leur
dire on s'allie au second tour de la
présidentielle et après cavalier seul
nous ne sommes pas les mêmes ce n'est
pas je vais apprendre qu'au premier tour
on choisit au deuxième on élimine donc
ce que nous avons fait c'est simplement
procéder à un choix de second tour qui
n'est pas un choix pour l'avenir merci
Gilles Moriconi merci Véronique on va
accueillir Frédéric Gimenez de l'Est
Républicain
alors Frédéric Gimenez il va arriver à
s'installer juste à côté de moi il a
choisi d'interroger nos candidats sur
une thématique bien précise inhérente à
cette première circonscription du Jura
Frédéric il s'agit du développement
économique et du respect de
l'environnement voilà avec un projet
très précis expliquez bonjour déjà à
travers le Center Parc de Poligny alors
bon on annonce c'est un dossier tout
d'abord qui va caractère mais qu'avant
son bonhomme de chemin avec des
motivations qu'on cherche peut-être un
peu des fois
il est présenté comme une opportunité
économique de l'emploi 500 emplois
pendant les travaux 300 à terme 120
millions d'euros d'investissement d'air
congés des des retombées économiques
mirrifiques on viendra de partout pour
admirer cette merveille de l'autre côté
on dit ça va bouffer 500 mètres cubes
d'eau par jour c'est un non-sens
écologique alors opportunité
économique ou non sens écologique madame
brulbrouat avait très envie de répondre
à cette question en coulisse je donne la
parole merci alors le projet de Center
Parcs bien sûr
intéressé les élus locaux et il a été
accueilli avec sympathie parce que quand
on est élu local on a pour priorité de
développer l'emploi l'activité des
entreprises elle attractivité de son
territoire et c'est un projet
particulièrement intéressant puisque
comme vous l'avez dit il propose 3 500
emplois en face de construction 300 en
phase d'exploitation 120 millions
d'euros de travaux pour les entreprises
ensuite il y a eu de nombreuses réunions
publiques il y a eu une enquête des
enquêtes il y a eu des investigations et
des argumentaires apportés par les
associations
opposante ou environnementales et donc
elles ont mis le doigt sur des points
importants qui est sont la question
environnementale avec en particulier
l'eau en tant que ressource mais aussi
en tant que eau usées et aussi la
question du financement et du montage
financier avec des financements publics
alors bien sûr moi j'ai été favorable à
ce projet comme tous les conseillers
départementaux toujours présents
[Musique]
ici on se pose dans la fonction d'un
député donc le rôle d'un député n'est
pas de substituer à la décision des élus
locaux et le rôle d'un député n'est
surtout pas de diviser la population ni
de la fracture
oui ou non vous maintenez votre soutien
au Center Parc pour le moment je ne me
prononce pas et je fais confiance aux
élus locaux et en particulier un mari
guide du fait monsieur bravo aujourd'hui
je veux surtout pas opposer le
développement économique d'un côté et
développement durable de l'autre oui
effectivement sur ce projet là quand on
prend les chiffres et j'ai les mêmes que
Madame bol c'est bien 170 millions qui
qui sont et non pas 120 il faut rétablir
aussi la vérité donc effectivement il y
a l'aubaine économique aujourd'hui nos
entreprises du bâtiment ont besoin de
ces 120 millions de travaux etc etc
aujourd'hui moi on a aussi une
responsabilité environnementale certes
le député vote les lois on est bien
d'accord mais il doit être aussi le
garant de l'aménagement du territoire
moi aujourd'hui j'ai des interrogations
sur ce projet là sur le principe sur le
principe je le soutiens parce que je me
dis que c'est une aubaine mais
j'aimerais avoir des réponses
environnemental sur les études de l'eau
il y en a deux qui sont sortis avec le
Syndicat des Eaux de polynéarbonne à
côté et ça serait compatible et le
polyné encore des études pour vous
prononcer aujourd'hui mais aujourd'hui
le problème c'est qu'au moment où on se
parle beaucoup de choses ont été éditées
écrites mais il y a aucun engagement je
dis bien aucun n'engagement qui n'a été
pas fait par les différentes parties
pourquoi parce que c'est justement pour
cela que j'apprécie ces études là pour
qu'on sache sur l'anciennisme les eaux
usées sur l'impact sur l'eau bon
d'ailleurs les dernières les dernières
études ont montré que c'était possible
je rappelle que c'est un million 250 000
m3 donc oui elle doit économique mais je
veux avoir des réponses
environnementales et je sais que je vais
les avoir notamment avec Dominique
bonnet le maire de Polini qui bat les
révéler dans les prochains jours bien
j'ai du Vernet ce projet
est l'illustration des pouvoirs
financiers et des multinationales car il
faut rappeler qu'il est porté par Pierre
et Vacances qui brasse des milliards
d'euros pour diviser et mieux régner les
populations les élus nous sommes contre
ce projet Center Parcs pour deux raisons
fondamentales
contre parce qu'on nous a menti
lorsqu'on était au conseil général
premièrement l'environnement 500 mètres
cubes d'eau par jour pour un modèle
touristique dépassé c'est l'équivalent
d'une production sur un territoire nous
avons fait le tour de certains paysans
notamment dans les circuit de proximité
de la consommation pour plus de 100
familles en une semaine 500 m3 alors que
nous subissons les sécheresses à
répétition en hiver ou en été dans le
Jura c'est inadmissible pour les je
finis car c'est inadmissible pour les
générations futures de dire qu'on ne se
prononce pas un élu il est là pour faire
respecter l'intérêt général et contre le
sens d'accord contre le symptôme parc et
deuxième point contre l'évasion fiscale
et les pouvoirs publics qui sont
derrière car il y a 87 millions d'euros
87 millions d'euros d'argent public
globalement investi alors que certaines
associations
je termine c'est important ce sont mes
deux raisons il faut que la parole
circule d'euros ou d'argent public nous
avons besoin face à la rareté de
l'argent public de le s'en servir
autrement marquant univerner ce projet a
été commencé à l'époque de Christophe
Perny président du conseil général vous
étiez à l'époque membre de la majorité
vous étiez opposé à ce projet on nous a
menti à l'époque on nous a clairement on
nous a clairement
mentielle 2014 je suis conforme à
l'intérêt général
l'intérêt général est de dire que nous
voterons contre nous militerons contre
aussi bien sur ce genre de projet que
l'accaparement des terres agricoles que
la transition écologique je ne parle pas
non plus d'autres projets
s'il vous plaît pour dire que nous
sommes contre le rassemblement
à ce que madame brûlebois avait déclaré
à l'époque je ne considère pas que un
Center Parc est un coin de paradis
exotique dans le Jura mais la loi
bah bien plus tard dans le raisonnement
alors donc je disais pour ce qui me
concerne puisqu'il s'agit de ne pas
faire croire aux électeurs qu'il s'agit
d'une élection locale mais bel et bien
d'une élection nationale nous avons
besoin donc d'une loi d'aménagement du
territoire d'un soutien au développement
du vineux du vignoble de l'agriculture
paysanne du tourisme diffus et familial
si attendu notamment par la Fédération
départementale du tourisme de plein air
du Jura et tout ceci peut se faire pour
25 millions d'euros de soutien d'argent
public pour créer 350 emplois vous voyez
que nous pouvons avec bien moins
d'argent développer une politique qui
correspond à la réalité du Jura plutôt
que en plein dérèglement climatique
amener une bulle tropicale à 28 degrés
nous n'avons que faire et qui ne répond
à aucun besoin de tourisme familial on a
bien compris votre position Gabriel Amar
Gilles Moriconi ben je crois que il faut
éviter de compliquer les choses simples
ce projet n'est pas tenable pour deux
raisons majeures la première c'est que
les collectivités
agissent financièrement de matière
beaucoup trop massive ce n'est pas aux
collectivités de financer et de gérer un
investissement de cet ordre et la
deuxième raison qui est très simple
c'est que Pierre et Vacances c'est dans
le rouge depuis 8 ou 9 ans et que on
sait très bien que sa seule porte de
sortie c'est la fuite en avant
mais dans cette opération celui qui va
gagner de l'argent l'investissent pas un
euro alors moi je suis industriel depuis
40 ans je ne savais pas qu'on pouvait
faire des investissements en faisant
appel à la puissance publique j'en
apprends j'ai appris ça récemment moi
j'ai tous je me suis toujours débrouillé
par moi-même cette démarche qui consiste
pour les collectivités à jouer au chef
d'entreprise me paraît particulièrement
risqué merci
pour prendre le risque de laisser une
friche en pleine forêt de Polini parce
qu'il s'agit de fonds de pension
volatile qui finance Pierre et Vacances
c'est scandaleux merci Frédéric
on va faire venir Véronique
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
Véronique revient elle va justement
sûrement vous demander de préciser
certaines choses les uns les autres
Véronique très rapidement pour que nos
candidats aient le temps de conclure à
commencer par une précision que je
voudrais demander à Gabriel Lamar vous
dites on peut faire du développement
économique vert créer 350 emplois
dites-vous avec 25 millions
d'investissements précisez-nous cette
envie de développement vert c'est pas
une envie c'est répondre à la tente des
vignerons jurassiens qui ont besoin de
300 hectares supplémentaires c'est
permettre l'autonomie alimentaire du
bassin de vie de Poligny en polyculture
et en maraîchage et enfin soutenir le
tourisme familial et diffus et ceci crée
350 emplois avec bien moins d'argent
public alors que le Center Parc c'est
220 équivalentes encore
une interpellation peut-être à Siri
breiro vous dites j'ai encore avant de
me prononcer j'ai besoin d'études Jérémy
le faisait remarquer ça fait quand même
quelques années que le dossier est à
l'étude on sait que Pierre et Vacances
et Monsieur Moriconi l'a dit et dans le
rouge vous doutez encore vous dites
c'est un c'est un bon projet aujourd'hui
je vous dis qu'on doit avoir une
responsabilité économique d'un côté et
par rapport au chiffre qui ont été qui
ont été évoqués et je les confirme
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas dire on ne
fait rien d'accord par contre la
responsabilité environnementale je
l'assume moi je veux quand même préciser
que quand on vote en 2014 au conseil
départemental et Madame rue de bois et
Monsieur Duvernet l'ont voté un prêt
accord c'était la délibération du 8
juillet 2014 je tiens les documents à
votre disposition et quand votre pour et
qu'on se retrouve trois ans après autour
d'une table ici à France 3 et qu'on nous
dit je suis conte le Center Parc je dis
c'est l'électoralisme politique moi j'ai
la j'assume aujourd'hui de dire oui à la
ben économique pour nos entreprises mais
on a une responsabilité environnementale
et avec ses études là nous pourrons
trancher vraiment à notre âme conscience
et monsieur morikoni a raison
effectivement Pierre et Vacances et dans
le rouge aujourd'hui et ça pose aussi
une question
on va revenir très vite chez Daniel
brûlebois se rétropédalage ou ce côté je
ne me prononce pas vous entendez que ça
ça choque vos concurrents moi je vous le
répète la décision ne se prendra pas de
toute manière à l'Assemblée nationale
moi je fais entièrement confiance aux
élus locaux qui portent ce projet et en
particulier à Madame Marie dufel la
présidente de région qui est une
gestionnaire responsable à la fois de la
protection de l'environnement et à la
fois des fonds publics et je pense que
nous aurions pu parler d'autres sujets
que Center Parc dans le dans l'économie
versus environnement il y a la
transition écologique pour lequel avec
Emmanuel Macron nous allons investir 15
millions d'euros dans la production
d'énergie
qui ont été dépensés d'argent public non
je suis désolé madame de faire inscrit
deux fois 8 millions d'euros d'études
pour les deux seins merci Gabriel Amar
on va si vous voulez conclure messieurs
et Madame il faut vous taire maintenant
parce qu'on va arriver à la conclusion
de l'émission vous avez 35 secondes
chacun pour vous adresser aux électeurs
et les convaincre de vouloir voter pour
vous dans une semaine Gilles Moriconi
vous commencez s'il vous plaît
moi ce que je voudrais juste dire c'est
que
la dernière élection présidentielle a eu
un mérite cette clarifier l'offre
politique je m'aperçois une fois de plus
que ceux qui sont pouvoirs depuis 40 ans
nous font encore des promesses qu'ils
seront évidemment pas tenus comme à
l'habitude donc notre démarche elle est
très claire nous nous opposons à ce qui
est en train de se mettre en place
c'est-à-dire via Macron une passerelle
qui va aller du Parti socialiste
républicain nous nous voulons créer une
véritable force d'opposition
souverainiste de droite
et
redéfinir un petit peu notre nouvelle
politique et un nouveau choix politique
pour l'avenir merci Gilles moricconi
Gabriel Amar oui d'abord dire aux
électeurs que ils ne se trompe pas
d'élection il s'agit là de savoir si on
isole le président de la République qui
nous prépare tel un monarque de casser
le code du travail ou d'augmenter la CSG
des retraités alors aux électeurs je dis
ne faites pas les moutons ne suivez pas
monsieur Macron parce que vous finirez
par être tondu préférée plutôt le
bulletin bleu avec marqué d'un Phi de
manière à choisir la vie plus douce plus
douce au travail plus douce à la maison
plus douce pour la terre indispensable à
la vie humaine plus douce aussi pour les
animaux et ainsi que viennent les jours
heureux merci
Gabriel amark Henri Duvernet nous avons
besoin de députés de gauche à
l'Assemblée nationale de députés qui
portent le rassemblement de la gauche et
de l'écologie nous l'avons fait dans le
Jura et nous avons besoin de siéger dans
l'OPP une vraie opposition constructive
pour lutter contre les ordonnances du
droit du travail qui vont le casser
sachez qu'en France aujourd'hui il y a
que 8% de travailleurs pauvres et c'est
toujours trop le modèle que vous nous
apposez en Allemagne c'est plus de 22%,
et cela ne travaille précaire comme on
veut faire au Center Parc des centaines
de femmes qui travaillent sur des temps
sécables de 9h par semaine et cela la
société que l'on veut on va se battre
contre cela contre la hausse de la CG
contre la hausse de la TVA pour nos
services publics de la poste de l'école
de l'hôpital et des lignes SNCF c'est
cela voter à gauche et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut voter pour notre asper si
Marc Henri Duvernet Daniel brulbois
notre circonscription a élu très
largement Emmanuel Macron président de
la République qui fait des débuts
remarquables qui a créé une véritable
dynamique européenne et nationale autour
de lui nous devons souhaiter qu'il
réussisse tous les événements tragiques
des dernières heures montrent que nous
avons autre chose à faire qu'à nous
opposer et à nous déchirer mais plutôt à
rester tous unis autour du président de
la République je suis la candidate je
suis la candidate du rassemblement des
Jurassiens qui veulent le changement et
le progrès vous me connaissez je suis
une élu de terrain j'aurai le cœur à
l'ouvrage de défendre notre
circonscription et de porter haut et
fort la voix du Jura avec le courage
politique que j'ai montré merci pour
conclure moi je vais vous dire que
député ça ne s'improvise pas moi
aujourd'hui j'ai derrière moi et je vais
d'ailleurs je ne suis plus assistant
parlementaire Jack spellissa depuis fin
mars c'est aussi l'honnêteté
intellectuelle d'être indépendant aussi
dans cette campagne par rapport à un
contrat droit privé moi j'ai
l'expérience de l'Assemblée nationale je
connais les rouages de l'Assemblée je
sais où tu as fait ou porte des
ministères parce que être député demain
c'est effectivement voter les lois mais
c'est aussi trouver des solutions pour
son territoire premier point deuxième
point j'ai une légitimité de proximité
je suis élu du territoire je connais la
circonscription et j'en connais les
dossiers et ce n'est pas juste une
approche nationale monsieur Amma c'est
aussi connaître les dossiers de sa
circonscription pour les faire avancer
donc moi demain je veux être un député
dans la majorité de la droite et du
centre parlementaire pour défendre
l'emploi le pouvoir d'achat mais aussi
les familles et la sécurité parce que
malheureusement les fêtes nous ont
montré ce matin quand on a bien besoin
frérot je précise que sont également
candidats sur cette circonscription
Gérard daubly Jean-Paul ecard Amazon
Ipek Alain Janiot Michel Lapierre
Benjamin maraud des grottes et Johan
Morel merci à tous les cinq merci